- So wait, your first really
big thing was "The Hangover"
- [Ken] Yup.
- And it's turning fifteen next year.
- Wow.
- Which is crazy.
(audience cheering)
- Incredible.
- Fifteen years.
So I have to ask,
because I heard that you,
it was your idea to jump
out of the trunk naked.
- [Ken] Yeah.
- Is that true?
- It was, I told Todd
Phillips the director,
it would be, 'cause I did
have slacks on in the script,
and I just said, "Wouldn't
it, just be so shocking?"
Because you had Mike
Tyson, you had the tiger,
that had already happened in the movie.
So I asked Todd, I said,
"Would, what do you think about
Mr. Chow jumping out naked?"
He's like, "You don't
have to tell me twice."
And so...
(crowd laughs)
- I love it.
- Literally, he made me sign a
nudity rider that I couldn't
change my mind to do it.
- [Kelly] Couldn't back out.
- Yeah, I couldn't back out.
- "You said it!"
- "You said you would do it!"
- "I got it here on contract!"
- Yeah. "Costner would do it!"
(people laughing)
Yeah, so I said okay.
- Are you brave enough?
- [Ken] Yeah.
- It was so, it was amazing,
though. I just love it.
That's a bold move.
- It was really just, honestly,
if it wasn't for "The Hangover",
I wouldn't be here between
either one of you right now.
I owe my career to "The
Hangover." So grateful.
- Honestly, well you owe
your career to your talent.
But yes, "The Hangover"
is where we saw you.
- But your talent is why.
- Oh, too kind.
(audience cheering)
- But are you like one of those people?
Are you okay with, I love being naked.
I'm okay with being naked.
Like a lot of people
aren't, like they are,
especially where I'm from in the South
that they're very conservative.
(person hums)
I am not from there internally.
(audience laughing)
Like yeah, I'm a total hippie.
- You know, I'm so shy.
Like in work...
- [Kelly] You are?
- Or I don't even like
to take my shirt off
to go to the beach.
I wear like those tight skin
like swim shirts when I go.
(audience laughing)
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- So for me, I think
just when the camera's on
I'm just locked in into...
- Is it 'cause you go into character mode?
- I think, I go into character mode,
(person exclaims)
so right now, I'm like,
"Hi, how are you doing?"
And then action (hand claps)
haha stupid. I don't know.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
(people laughing)
- It just, it's a different thing, yeah.
- Okay.
- [Ken] Yeah.
- You just made me feel
weird in real life,
but it's totally fine.
(people laughing)
- No, I'm not saying you're weird.
- I am. I just thought most people aren't,
and I figured you had to be comfortable
if you'd do it on film, but nope.
(person sighs)
- Isn't that insane?
- I don't wanna be naked
or in the trunk of a car.
(people laughing)
Neither.
- You would never do that in a movie?
- Uh, no, I'm shameless.
I'd do it too. Yeah.
(people laughing)
- Yeah. It's funny.
- Maybe it's something
about comedy too, you know.
- [Charlie] Yeah.
- Just taking taking
bold choices, big swings,
that kind of thing. Yeah.
- Yeah. You know, I'm joking,
I don't know that I
would've wanted to do that.
That was gutsy man. Yeah.
(people laughing)
Well done.